I've listened to all of the podcasts
before asking this question can you
please explain how do you deal or have
dealt with your insecurities thank you
very much for you I guess broadly
fundamentally what I'm gonna do with my
insecurities um is I'm gonna confront
them I'm gonna put them out there I'm
gonna own them I'm gonna hone them I'm
gonna own my insecurities uh if I had to
think of examples of situations where
insecurities came into play for me one I
was going through buds basic SEAL
training and there was an event called
pool competency where you are wearing
your underwater breathing apparatus your
scuba gear and they do all these
horrible things to you and it's a very
hard evolution and I failed it and I was
confident going into because I kind of
done well most of the water things
underwater knot-tying life savings etc
etc etc I had done what I was
comfortable in the water mm-hmm and so I
was a I when I failed this thing which
was which was I was freaked out you know
and because people would fail pool comp
and get kicked out of buds you know it's
a nightmare for me
so I fail and by the way if you fail so
you take it on Friday and then if you
fail you take it again on Monday and if
you fail again
you're rolled the back and then once you
rolled back now you fail something else
and you're gone so it's a nightmare for
me I mean I'm I'm completely I've gone
from confidence to insecurity about this
thing so what did I do me and a couple
of the other guys we I don't know why
the instructors let us do this they
could probably get in trouble for it but
they they let us take the scuba gear and
use it in the dip tank which is just a
big bucketful oh I mean a big container
full of water probably four feet deep
and it's probably eight feet long by
four feet wide so it's just a small
where it's where you will you take fresh
water and you put things to clean it
you put in fresh we call it a dip tank
so they they let us fill the dip tank up
of totally unsupervised and we went in
there we pool comped each other so we
ripped each other's masks off beat each
other to hell and just trashed ourselves
and by the time I went on Monday I was
that insecurity that I had was now gone
because we had been so frickin harsh to
each other that by the time I was
rolling there I was like yeah this isn't
even insecurity I'm like burning it go
bring what you got I'm ready so that's a
that's one way to overcome or that I
look at is something I was insecure
nervous about right how am I going to
overcome it I'm going to attack it I'm
gonna I'm gonna go straight into that
thing into that insecurity another thing
I was thinking about was kind of funny
was I was like at a bar when I was young
and single and whatever hanging out you
know having some beverages and I'm
chatting with some girl that I met and
you know as we're talking were just kind
of just talking having a good time
whatever and she's like ah you know what
do you do you know well I'm a dental
hygienist she's a dental hygienist and
although that's cool
and then she says like something like
you know we could take care of that gap
in your teeth and like without missing a
beat I'm like huh
are you serious I didn't know that you
could expand gaps how much bigger could
you get and you know like she was she
was like totally I don't know if the
word stoked but she realized that this
whatever you know this gap between my
teeth which some people might have is a
big insecurity like oh you know cover
your mouth those fine like there it is
I'm making fun of it basically make it
so that's I think that is
the bottom line when you have some kind
of in something that you're insecure
about it well if it's something that you
can take control over Colt then attack
it and get good at it you know if you're
if you're insecure about talking in
front of people cool attack that problem
and get better at it if you're insecure
about you know confrontations with
people start training jiu-jitsu if
you're insecure or whatever whatever
you're insecure about do it more if
you're insecure if you think I every
time I write an email I feel like I'm
you know it's it looks like jong-kul
write more get better at writing it so
there's insecurities that you have like
that that you can attack if there's
something that you can't change or that
you can't control then just get it out
there and have fun with it as far as I'm
concerned you know dude make does that
make sense
is that a bad answer well that's a good
answer in fact it's those very clever
response to the dental hygienist
the dental hygienist wanting to fix the
gap in my teeth